la parole est à monsieur arnaud robinet
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à la ministre des affaires
sociales et de la santé
il n'est pas si loin le tort de la
gauche qui voulait changer la vie en
promettant monts et merveilles qui fut
symbolisée en eau entre autres par votre
lointain prédécesseur
nicole questiaux ministre des affaires
sociales de françois mitterrand qui
déclarait qu'elle ne serait jamais je
cite la ministre des comptes 33 ans plus
tard à cette gauche dépensière s'ajoute
la gauche se d'auge estiot nerfs qui
gouverne à la petite semaine à modèle
social à bout de souffle les inégalités
d'accès aux soins persiste vous
promettez la complémentaire santé pour
tous mais vous l'annoncer pas avant 2017
les 35 heures a fixé les hôpitaux
publics parisiens vous ordonnez alors
directeur de reculer devant les
syndicats
on prévoit un déficit des retraites de
15 milliards en 2020 vous dégainez des
prévisions illusoire basé sur une
croissance de 2%
on annonce la faillite de la retraite
complémentaires du secteur privé
vous vous défausser vers les partenaires
sociaux madame la ministre vous
ressembler de plus en plus à ce bon
docteur kay qui avait pour devise
il est urgent de rien faire dans le
désert de mauvaises nouvelles qui
caractérise votre gouvernement vous
cherchez le moindre oasis de résultats
positifs
tout dernièrement vous avez été jusqu'à
vous réjouir déficit de la sécurité
sociale qui avoisine à peu près entre
guillemets les 10 milliards d'euros
et pourtant il n'ya pas de quoi pavoiser
la situation des deux branches s'aggrave
déficit de l'assurance maladie et de
l'assurance vieillesse se creuse
atteignant respectivement 600 et 700
millions d'euros par rapport à vos
perspectives
évidemment vous pouvez encore et encore
augmenter les cotisations retraite
vous pouvez tirer hypocritement partie
de leurs résultats de la réforme des
retraites de 2010 voulues par nicolas
sarkozy est portée par françois fillon
eric woerth
vous pouvez taxer toujours plus et
industries de santé une succession de
nos réformes de dérobade et de 49,3 ne
fait pas une politique
alors madame la ministre quand
comptez-vous enfin relever le défi du
modèle social français avec l'ensemble
des parties prenantes
devant un tel risque de faillite du
système ce n'est plus maire sur de
droite ni de gauche mais à voir l'état
madame marisol touraine ministre des
affaires sociales
de la santé et des droits des femmes
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
arnaud robinet à dire vrai je ne sais
plus très bien par quel bout prendre
votre question parce que vous venez vous
venez de me changer
allez allez allez allez la faillite qui
a été celle du gouvernement
vous trouvez que le gouvernement en
ayant ramené le déficit de la sécurité
sociale à 10 milliards d'euros en trois
ans alors que vous vous l'aviez laissée
à 25 milliards d'euros seraient en
situation difficile mais alors comment
qualifiez vous votre propre résultat
vous considérez que nous ne portons pas
le modèle social français alors que vous
avez laissé s'installer les déserts
médicaux que vous avez multiplié les
franchises et les déremboursements et
que vous avez laissé se creuser les
inégalités en matière de santé
et puisque nous parlons de santé nous
prenons à bras le corps cette situation
en faisant en sorte que des médecins
s'installent dans les territoires en
difficulté dix nouveaux médecins se sont
installés dans votre département
monsieur robinet alors qu'il n'y en
avait pas nous faisons en sorte que les
hôpitaux soient confortés dans leurs
missions au quotidien en rétablissant le
service public hospitalier nous faisons
en sorte que les inégalités de santé
disparaissent en permettant notamment la
mise en place du tiers payant généralisé
alors que vous laissez des hommes et des
femmes en difficultés
renoncer à des soins et puisque vous
évoquez également la situation des
retraites monsieur le député vous qui
avez défendu la loi présenté par le
gouvernement que vous souteniez je
comprends que vous soyez mal à l'aise
lorsque vous devez constater qu'en 2011
vous nous avez laissé un déficit de 6
milliards d'euros pour les retraites que
nous arrivons à d'autres économies vont
dire monsieur le député à nos
concitoyens que leurs retraites seront
versés et que dans la durée
système de retraites des français mais
rompt centimes